So now you have a small neural network.
It's not particularly deep,
just two layers.
You can make it bigger, more complex,
by increasing the size of that
hidden layer in the middle.
But it turns out that increasing
this H is not particularly
efficient in general.
You need to make it very, very big,
and then it gets really hard to train.
This is where the central idea of
deep learning comes into play.
Instead, you can also add more
layers and make your model deeper.
There are lots of good
reasons to do that.
One is parameter efficiency.
You can typically get much more
performance with fewer parameters
by going deeper rather than wider.
Another one is that a lot of
natural phenomena that you might be
interested in,
tend to have a hierarchical structure
which deep models naturally capture.
If you poke at a model for
images, for example, and
visualize what the model learns,
you'll often find very simple things at
the lowest layers, like lines or edges.
Once you move up,
you tend to see more complicated
things like geometric shapes.
Go further up and you start seeing
things like objects, faces.
This is very powerful because the model
structure matches the kind of
abstractions that you might
expect to see in your data.
And as a result the model has
an easier time learning them.